felizmente inconscientes estos bañistas
del suroeste de francia apenas notaron
las gruesas columnas de humo que se
elevaban en la distancia pero una semana
después los dos grandes incendios
forestales de hierro se han salido de
control el primero comenzó a cerca de
arcachón el 13 de julio consumiendo 700
hectáreas de tierra en un solo día y
luego dirigiéndose hacia el sur a toda
velocidad las autoridades esperaban que
el incendio no se extendiera más allá de
la carretera de 218 pero la última línea
de defensa de los bomberos se dio el
domingo por la noche seis días después
el fuego se extendió por una zona de
nueve por ocho kilómetros hacia el norte
de arcachón calor abrazador sequía y
viento cada día se declaran unos 22
incendios forestales en la zona dejando
a los bomberos luchando aumenta la
presión haz lo más alto no podemos hacer
nada
más hacia el interior otro incendio
forestal se ha extendido sin control
se desató en las vidas del 12 de julio
en menos de una semana devoró 10 mil 500
hectáreas de bosque un área que mide 14
por 9 kilómetros los residentes de al
menos 13 pueblos de la zona se vieron
obligados a evacuar estos los incendios
forestales y han destruido casi 150
kilómetros cuadrados una superficie del
tamaño de parís y sus alrededores
sólo en una semana 36 mil personas
tuvieron que evacuar sus hogares en
gijón
tiene que irse señor peter tiene que
irse por el humo los más recientes
incendios forestales no son los peores
registrados en la región no en francia
en 1949 50.000 hectáreas de pinos
terminaron en cenizas en cuestión de
días eso es tres veces peor que los
incendios forestales actuales 82
personas murieron en aquel entonces